in tonight's whatever happened to
segment one of our viewers asks whatever
happened to the Pakistani doctor who
helped the CIA confirm the compound
where Osama bin Laden was hiding that
doctor was later imprisoned by the
Pakistani government well as part of the
omnibus spending bill signed today by
President Trump 33 million dollars is
being withheld from Pakistan until that
doctors release tonight correspondent
Connor Powell has the story the United
States has conducted an operation that
killed Osama bin Laden the leader of
al-qaeda President Obama's announcement
on the evening of May 1st 2011 marked
the end of one of America's largest
manhunts in history Americans across the
country celebrated bin Laden's demise
and the raid of the terror masterminds
compound produced a treasure trove of
information on al Qaeda's operations but
none of it would have happened without
the help of a little-known Pakistani
physician dr. Shakil Afridi dr. Afridi
was critical to capture a kill Osama bin
Laden because he ran a vaccination
program for hepatitis that allowed us to
confirm the DNA of terrorists in the
area but specifically for the bin Laden
family while fraidy and the Navy SEALs
that undertook the raid were immediately
hailed as heroes in the United States
back at home in Pakistan dr. Alfred E is
not hailed as a hero but instead as a
traitor following the bin Laden raid
Pakistani authorities arrested dr.
Afridi and sentenced him to 33 years in
prison his charge treason in an
exclusive interview from his jail cell
with Fox News in 2012 dr. Alfred II
detailed his torture at the hands of
Pakistan's infamous intelligence service
the ISI dr. Alfred II described how he
had been burned with cigarettes and
shocked with electricity while ISI
officers cursed America
as a candidate Donald Trump vowed to
secure dr. Afridi's release telling Fox
News in April of 2016 he could get it
done in two minutes two minutes I would
tell them let them out and I'm sure
they'd let him out because we give a lot
of aid to Pakistan we gave a lot of
money to Pakistan the Trump
administration has significantly cut
financial aid to Pakistan in hopes of
pushing Islamabad away from its
historical and traditional ties to
militants but so far Pakistani leaders
have refused president Trump's multiple
requests to release dr. Alfred E who
continues to languish in a Pakistani
prison to this day Brett can repeal in
our Middle East newsroom
Connor thank you